Surveillance Droid reports rebel activity in
the area
you two move along this area is threat
level Orange move along
hello I was sent from Malastare.
thank you
thank you we could not have done this
without you
I think this is some kind of drill
TK-904 reporting in.
we have a positive ID on a terrorist
vehicle let's check it out
copy that
the plans have been acquired
we will need weapons and your best
soldiers
we will also need a ship.
this console
has been compromised lock down the area
search the vehicle
alert team 2 of our situation.
we have a ship.
cruiser class?
Team 2 reporting in.
I think I'm being followed.
Initiate search!
Proceed with caution.
get in the back
let's go
nobody move
who is the owner of the speeder outside
Team 1
attempting entry into vehicle.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of the new Star
Wars underworld TV show footage that
just dropped so this is actually ten
years old if you can believe it we've
all been watching the Mandalorian series
in present day that's sort of the
successor to this show a lot of the
stuff that this TV show is going to be
the underworld of the Star Wars universe
literally in the title of the TV show is
what the Mandalorian became if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a new
baby Yoda giveaway because they're
finally selling merch all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and let
me know what you think would have
happened on this TV series if it had
gotten made think of this is sort of a
prequel to the Mandalorian series just
because it's dealing with the bounty
hunters of the Star Wars universe and
that's basically what the Mandalorian
series is even though the plot of the
Mandalorian wound up becoming something
very different as you can see with the
footage it's kind of meant to visually
look like Blade Runner meets Star Wars
in Deadwood the TV series in space they
kind of called it Deadwood in space
because when they were conceiving this
series right after Revenge of this is
starting in around 2005 it was right
around the time the early 2000s when
Deadwood and the wire were happening
they didn't actually start making the TV
series till a couple years after that
but they wrote up to 50 episodes worth
of scripts and if you can believe it the
reason why this series didn't get made
because it would have been amazing to
have a live-action TV series like the
Mandalorian ten years ago it's all
because of the budget because about ten
years ago things were nowhere near the
level of technology that they are today
as they're making the Mandalorian series
you've probably been seeing all the
recent articles that have been going
around about how they film the
Mandalorian they have this revolutionary
projection screen technology where they
can literally mimic environments in real
time is there panning around actors on
sound stages they literally generate the
environment around the actor in real
time as it's happening so no more the
green and the blue screens that you saw
and all the behind the scenes from the
prequel movies but as you can see
because this is happening 10 years ago
and they started making it right after
the prequels a lot of the visual style
mimics the visual style of the prequels
and that was part of the intention
something said during the events of the
classic trilogy but with the level of
technology that they used when they were
making the prequels within this actual
test footage and this trailer here
what's happening is used to have a rebel
spy that's trying to steal plan
for a Star Destroyer it wouldn't be a
Star Wars story if someone weren't
trying to steal plans to do something to
the Empire but the basic intention of
the series is the exact same as what's
happening with the Mandalorian series
following the lesser characters the
Bounty Hunter characters that you see in
the background of the main movies being
more of a character based series about
the supposed dirtbags of the Star Wars
universe although as we've learned in
the Mandalorian serious not everything
is what it seems
careful for spoilers for Star Wars rise
of Skywalker because there was some
stuff happening during Star Wars
underworld this sort of connects to
what's happening in rise of Skywalker
and some of you may not have seen the
movie yet so during rise of Skywalker we
find out that Rey is actually a
Palpatine and her father was Palpatine's
natural born son we don't know who
Palpatine was married to if he was ever
married or who he got busy with to have
his son but the idea of the Star Wars
underworld series is that one of the big
villain characters or at least one of
the main characters maybe not a villain
was going to be a woman who was
romantically involved with Emperor
Palpatine and then screwed him over I
think it was them trying to involve
Palpatine and Vader in this Star Wars
underworld TV series as much as possible
without having them on screen every
single week the visual effects studio
that was trying to work on the series is
the one that made this footage this
trailer and it actually looks really
good if you consider what the prequels
look like although between the time they
finished making Phantom Menace and then
they made Revenge of the Sith the
technology had advanced quite a bit just
in those couple of years that had gone
by you also probably notice that this
bares a lot of similarities to the Star
Wars 1313 game that was also going to
cover the underworld in the bounty
hunters of the Star Wars universe it was
being developed around the same time
they were developing this live-action TV
series they even showed off some footage
at e3 in 2012 as well see if there's any
place more comfortable on this rust
bucket it's a long way down
down yeah down the Rings aren't on
Corson's they're underneath it
it's deep breath it'll be the last fish
here you'll get for a while
fresh Air's overrated let's see how you
feel about that after you get a thousand
levels down
if you think that's awesome and you're
kind of upset that they never wind up
releasing that I think it just got lost
in the shuffle when Disney bought
Lucasfilm there were a bunch of projects
that went away
remember they kind of got rid of Clone
Wars to do Star Wars rebels cut to
present-day on Disney Plus we're getting
ready to watch the Clone Wars season
seven watch them close down that series
so who knows maybe someday they'll bring
back Star Wars 1313 in some different
form you have to imagine that George
Lucas was pretty free with the money and
development on new Star Wars properties
he was pretty forward-thinking when it
came to doing Star Wars he was really
hyped up about doing a live-action
series so I'm sure there's all kinds of
deleted scenes test footage just hidden
in the archives at Lucasfilm hopefully
in the future they'll find a way to
incorporate that into the new TV series
that are doing like the Mandalorian but
everyone posted reactions to all this
footage in the comments below how cool
would it have been to get a series like
the Mandalorian ten years ago just a
reminder to the Star Wars Clone Wars
episodes are happening in a couple weeks
I'll remind everyone they'll probably
another trailer - that'll drop I will do
episode videos and Easter eggs for Clone
Wars season seven there's a big black
widow super bowl trailer happening
tomorrow I'll do a video for that and
there should be some big stuff happening
next week - so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
all those videos when I post them every
one click here for my brand new
Mandalorian season 2 video and click
here for that brand new Avengers 5
Marvel announcement thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
this is the way!